what are you doing you out here running  around  yeah  what are you running around i heard you  i know you're acting all casual like you  weren't just doing something like five  seconds ago  running around like a crazy person yeah  you acting natural like you weren't  doing something  as soon as mommy turns her back she's  going to be like  running up down the hall like a little  her buffalo how do you feel about that  bookie how do you feel about that you  did you sound like a little heard of  buffalo she's like what's what's his  oh my goodness  i think she smelled my nail polish  she was like painting my nails and she  was just like i don't like that  i'm sorry pookie i offended you  okay you're mad i get it  i get it i'm sorry